hi my name is Winston Duke hi I'm defeat
Daniel oh and we're here playing a
horror themed version of would you
rather you ready to lose well you know
ah
she got a knot there would you rather
come home to your child would you rather
be the last one murdered out of your
friend group or be the only one who
survives yeah there's that thing they
call survival versus guilt that wouldn't
be fun
what is that yeah I think I would like
to survive and tell their story it
depends on how they died - I would never
choose death yeah I don't think yeah
we're positive over here I mean and
we're just like this award to all my
homey would you rather get attacked by a
bunch of rabid birds at the beach or a
bunch of scarecrows in a corn maze come
on I'll take the birds I don't take the
birds - because the beach you can run as
far as if bars you want corn maze that's
I think you're missing the obvious
terrible thing here if scarecrows attack
you it means you're in a world full of
scarecrows that come alive they are
alive scarecrows are not alive
are they not Oh
okay yeah scarecrows no in a corn maze
no no would you rather hear a loud noise
upstairs when you're home alone at night
or have your car break down on a creepy
abandoned highway while you're alone
this this could get political Oh break
it down a night I know there's a lot
more coming for you think about that so
I think I'd like to be at home I think
so because the loud noise could be a
bunch of things when you're at yeah
would you rather have to live through a
zombie apocalypse or an alien abduction
Wow through it I'm an I'm scared of
heights and my concern is if there was
an alien abduction it would mean having
to go up and so for that reason alone I
would prefer the zombie apocalypse I've
also you know I've had my zombie
training you know I'll be training so
feeling kind of I feel I would do the
alien abduction you'd like to travel I
like to travel first class
I think alien abduction makes me think
that it's just me that's being abducted
and I don't want to live through a
zombie apocalypse where potentially my
family dies and gets eaten by zombies
would you rather go camping in a forest
no I wouldn't but okay and of course to
go camping in a forest that's haunted by
an evil witch for an entire weekend or
spend one night sleeping in a room full
of haunted dolls the haunted dolls all
day mmm I don't like to camp period
that's it that's so far the toughest
question you're showering out of a cup
yeah that's true
and I vibe eating marshmallows or
whatever and then there's a haunted evil
witch I mean haunted dolls they're just
dolls but if they're like Chucky I mean
I don't like hauntings
I don't want it yeah I think so which
heart I you know there could be other
stuff than out in the woods I don't
woods no you don't know about that yeah
I think she might be one of many things
out there so I'm just gonna do the room
yes I think it's safer in there would
you rather get trapped in the sunken
place for 24 hours or be stopped by your
doppelganger from us for a week by your
doppelganger from us for a week's mean
they're trying to kill you there's a
chance you could die yeah and then
trapped in the sunken place of 24 hours
I mean I mean you come out yeah and the
question is like what version of the
sunken place are you in now you in the
version where someone else is using your
body and you're like you know what do
you want you just want to see your face
for the first time on somebody else
don't lie I think I would taste the
sunken place yeah I'll go there with you
yeah unison it's new territory it was
like rather be in Jordan peels mind or
in Jordan feels fine
[Laughter]